boogie nights when we when we talk about
boogie nights i mean
was boogie night supposed to be as big
as it was
did you did was that was that movie a
movie that you took on with the
expectations of this is going to change
my life it was definitely going to it
could have been really good which it
ended up being or could have been really
bad we really didn't know um the subject
matter was pretty out there um the only
other thing that was even kind of in the
same
uh box that you could compete to with
show girls which ended up being a
disaster but paul had um had the movie
heart eight which people were really
enjoying and you know he had had some
some some nice accolades off of that
movie
um but it was one of those things where
it was a challenge and it was crazy
exciting so if i was going to go to
really try to do something as an actor
so far off of who people knew me from
from my musical career up until that
point
and it was also a challenge as an actor
to play vulnerable
and because the character was very he
was he was insecure he had a lot of [ __ ]
going on yeah he wasn't he wasn't this
confident he wasn't a confident porn
star he was a guy that was that was
trouble he was a child yeah it was very
young so for me it was a great
opportunity to just go for it as an
actor and take a swing and then by the
time we finished that movie i was like
okay we gotta line up two more that are
more commercial and do those as well
was that a movie where
where you understood or learned the
importance of trusting in the director
because you're young as [ __ ] though
absolutely we were both we were both 25
at the time oh we were having a blast we
kind of like the studio left us alone we
were out there just trying stuff but
then you had bert
god rest her soul who was in a bit of a
mid i wouldn't even say midlife crisis
he was having this impossible he was
having a meltdown because this guy was
the biggest star in the world you know
for 10 years yeah he was the biggest
star in the world at the box office and
now here he is having to say things
that he didn't want to say that he
wasn't comfortable saying yeah right
he's a porn director so he's telling
people what to do and how to do it he
was just like it drove him crazy and he
didn't really embrace the movie
until after
he realized that everybody loved it and
he could have won he should have won the
office what was your relationship with
bert on set yeah
very much very much he always looked at
me like a son okay but he didn't
understand that i was kind of in on the
joke and thought that the movie was good
i remember him grabbing me trying to
grab me in a headlock at the premiere of
the new york film festival and this
guy's i don't know why i like this kid
but let's just go with it huh
let's just go with it i'm like dude this
[ __ ] is already of [ __ ] smash
what are you talking about you got your
headlight on the red carpet oh my god
i'm messing up yeah if i put him in a
headlock his hair falls off and all
kinds of [ __ ] that wouldn't have been a
good look you know he already had a
little thing with paul and everything
and he's he was you know
he was a guy who had an amazing career
and i you know i really really respected
him and looked up to him well that's
just such a it's such a good move it's
just such a hard thing for him
to embrace i was going to say that you
got it you said it i mean you said that
perfectly 10 years when you're 10 years
and you're at the top and there is no
question of who and what and it's all
just really pure entertainment americana
he would take the swings like with
deliverance and stuff like that to show
what he was capable of doing as an actor
but the movies he was the guy
you know
you